let me bring in Charles Barkley the Hall
of Famer NBA on TNT analyst Charles let
me start with the poll question McLovin
give Charles the poll question what are
you more confident will happen the
Warriors will win the NBA title or Kyla
Marie will go number one overall to the
Arizona Cardinals I'm not confident
either I don't know what Arizona's going
to do and I don't think the Warriors are
gonna win the championship personally
who do you think will win the
championship well a month ago I picked
the Trail Blazers before the big fella
got hurt
so I still like Portland in the West Wow
I still like Portland the East I got no
idea I got no idea was gonna win the
East but a month ago I picked Portland
and I'm gonna stick with that yeah I got
Houston and I think they played
extremely well they played good defense
second half of the season they feel like
they're a little bit more cohesive than
Golden State is right now even though
Golden State's a lot more talented but I
got the Rockets for some reason not
gonna mount next round what do you think
they both get there I mean they aren't
passive or I mean obviously the wards
have got to beat the Clippers but that's
gonna be a very good series if they play
but like I say before Newark egde got
hurt
I thought the Trailblazers was the one
out getting rotten as a encounter made
them the favorites in the West and I
still liked them in the West explain
this or clarify this I don't know if you
said this last night or not if Toronto
doesn't get to the conference finals
then Kawhi Leonard is gone from Toronto
did I have that right I believe I
believe it I think they don't they lose
offense if they lose the first round
which I don't think they'll lose to
Orlando
I think they probably got to the
conference finals or to the finals that
he's going to leave I hope he stays but
I if they don't go deep deeper the
players I think he's got to leave if you
were going to pick somebody hand pick a
head coach for the Lakers who would you
pick right now well that's not my job to
pick the head coach that's the brothers
job who do you think LeBron is gonna
pick I think he's gonna take tyloo
somebody he trusts we know such the
Lakers are really on the clock right now
I mean listen we got to be realistic the
bronze probably you know the Lakers are
really on the clock before it's been a
contender I mean of LeBrons going to
tear 17-year they got to get not just
they got to get another superstar or
they go they won't be any good for the
next three or four years I told you man
this is gonna be the craziest most
interesting summer in NBA history
because everybody can't get the
superstars we got a bunch of teens with
salary cap space but hey we don't have
enough superstars to go around so it's
gonna be really interesting this summer
because some of these teams going to
ruin their franchise put it next ten
years cuz they gonna pay good players
max dollars and they just gonna be a
good team and not a great team do you
think magic realized that he thought he
was in charge and then realized he
wasn't in charge and then decided look
if I can't fire these guys then I'm just
gonna step down you know that's an
interesting scenario I don't know
exactly what happened in LA to be honest
was because you know other than the
Anthony Davis situation I don't think
anything have what the Lakers I don't
think anything has happened with the
Lakers I think if they hadn't gotten
half a Davis that would have changed
here the whole dynamic of their season
they didn't get him and this other stuff
about magic not being working
other stuff I think that's a relevant to
be honest with you talking to Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer NBA on TNT
analyst I agreed with you on Joelle and
beads elbow to Jared Allen's jaw there
although Jack didn't agree with you in
in looking at it again and discussing
that do you should that have been a
flagrant two on Joelle MB yeah of course
it should have been I should have been a
flagrant two and he should have gotten
ejected ejected I mean I was really and
then to compounded I didn't appreciate
that laugh and you know was it an
accident
yeah it was an accident but that doesn't
mean anything and then laughing after
the game I think was a big mistake
because of on the culture the net I
ain't gonna say anything about X's and
O's I'm just going to put them laugh and
on a real and say this is what these
guys think about they don't have zero
respect for us even though we won the
first game I got home court they're not
taking us seriously made in this job
really easy going in the game tree I'm
just gonna say hey guys this is what
they think of us they don't respect us
they think it's alright to just hit our
players and joke about it so I think the
Sixers made a mistake also when I'm
watching the Clippers the other night
and I turned it off when they were
getting blown out but the interesting
part was when they traded Tobias Harris
and Patrick Beverley goes to management
says uh hey are we tanking riggo's no
we're not and who would have thought
that the Clippers would even steal a
game from Golden State make the playoffs
and they have a brighter future than the
Lakers do right now you don't have a
brighter future in the Lakers I don't
believe all the any of you know they
don't if the Lakers if the Lakers get
after the Davis there's no money well
you don't know that I mean he's with
clutch sports you don't know that I
don't think first of all let's get one
thing we don't know who got a bright
future that's that what the point I just
made it's all going to come down to
where all these superstars go to this
summer
and nobody has a bright future yet I
mean if after that Davis goes to the
Lakers
they're gonna be back in play but I
don't this notion that somebody's got an
advantage nobody has an advantage I
think the Lakers the Clippers the nets
and the Knicks I think it's gonna be
that's something well I think whoever
gets these superstar is going to be in
play and the rest of the team just gonna
be screwed for the next few years cuz
they want to spend that money now if you
get just a couple good players and you
just a five or six seed I think it's
gonna ruin your French eyes you got to
get you got to get listen let's be
realistic I think there's only two guys
out there after Davis and KB let's go
make you an instant contender now these
other guys and and collides a hell of a
player also I don't want to I said put
him in that category if you don't get
one of those three guys I don't like I
said you might get a guy in Panamax but
unless you get one of those three guys
you're not a contender
where would a 28 year old Charles
Barkley want to play if you're a free
agent I would like to play the 15 the
city that drafted me I mean you know
there's there is a some loyalty to one
of these I respect dirt Nowitzki
I respect named Lillard you know if
there's some law that when you've been
with a franchise X amount of years you
know I'm not chasing I want to play in
the same city that drafted me I'm not
gonna move I'm not gonna try to change
the championship and things like that I
don't believe in that but do you regret
going to Houston are the sons traded me
to Houston I didn't want to go to
Houston I want to finish my career yeah
in Phoenix they traded me but it didn't
matter I couldn't play anymore at that
point you know I mean I was I had
already been an NBA for 12 years I was
on the downside but I never want to
leave and if they traded me and that was
and I had no control over that he's
Charles Barkley Hall of Famer NBA on TNT
analyst I was I talked to Chris Webber
about this that you had the Joelle
embiid
Johnson phone thing on the bench with
the 76ers is c-webb what's the strangest
thing that he saw on the bench in all of
his years he said Vlade Divac would go
get a kid and bring the kid and put him
on his lap and then they would have food
on the on the bench you'll get a fan and
blow out he'd have the kids sit on his
lap and they'd eat hot dogs do you have
a story of craziest thing you saw on a
bench no not really first of all good
teams don't do that you ever notice all
these stories
what stuff stupid happened on the bench
you'd ever noticed that always happening
to the bad things it's funny though like
when you go back and look at sports
think about it Dan go back and think
about I've been in sports like it's just
84 I've been in the NBA all the stupid
stuff to happen in sports it always
happened to the bad teams but they have
like no rules and regulations they have
no culture they'd be good teams don't
let stuff like that happen it only
happened to the stupid teams did you did
you bet on Tiger on Sunday I don't bet
on golf you draw a line at all yeah that
was one of the greatest things it was so
cool to watch you know I'm a big big
tiger I mean first of all I mean all the
guy loved Tiger but it was really cool
especially with all the injuries and
things that he's been through you know I
mean his body has been through hell the
last few years and for him to come back
and win it was just one of the greatest
things I've ever seen
if you could trade your life for Tigers
life his career I don't trade my life
for nobody brother I listen
that's not even Michael Jordan Magic
Johnson Larry Bird I'm doing pretty good
for a guy from Leeds Alabama I would not
trade my life and I'm not saying that to
be you know like hater or whatever where
I can't even take the word I want to use
I'm
pretty happy with my life you wouldn't
trade chat for shanks life I thought you
what's the closest you guys ever came to
now I know you guys had your altercation
on the floor but you know on the set
have you ever really come close to let
it's go time with you and check never
okay
never I like messing with it so I told
you got since I told you gotta stay in
the Flat Stanley I like messing with
he's a great dude but he's very
sensitive and I like messing with him
but man he's a great dude but I just
like messing with him
and I know things get on this peanut
gets under my skin I mean nothing's get
on my skin but I love getting out of his
skin it's fun is LeBron gonna join you
on set I know you reach down to him I
hope so it'd be fun man you guys a great
great player he's a good good man after
gonna be fun you know obviously we ain't
gonna do nothing to upset of my anything
but I'll be comes on it'd be fun
oh you got a needle him a little bit oh
yeah we'll probably need him a little
bit I mean come on you know they like
you've got anything to do he's free he
says he got a he's got a hope he comes
it'll be fun
he's got space jams too well he can't
apparently did he invite you know
invited me but I tell you what since he
can't get into these young boys of being
an I give them a discount I'll take
three times what Michael paid me back in
the day maybe four times but in my
opinion oh I'm trying to it was a lot
back there for
for a few days worked like 50,000
100,000 man I wouldn't open my door
thousand dollars are you kidding me did
he have a basketball court there on set
on space Jim Jordan
yeah great we had great scrimmages every
night he had a fly Michael was so
powerful then we had a full basketball
court
we had a full weight room and yeah it
stands up I want to say up to 5,000
people I mean that's how great I mean it
was awesome I mean I said we would film
all day we had a full weight room they
built it in like a bubble had a full
weight room a full basketball court and
stands for I think I think you could get
up to five thousand people in there it
was amazing now it's intact but the
games were probably better than the
movie right
Oh Jim's a great movie dad won't agree
all the time stop being a hater a great
movie it was a great movie at the time
okay Jim was a great movie at the time I
mean it actually believed that I have
people to this day still come up it
holds up well over time are you still
getting residuals from that movie I
don't think so I don't keep up with
stuff like that I mean you know then
I'll get a check for a couple of dollars
on like I said my live yeah I'll get
like a couple hundred dollars every time
they show remake a repeater us and I
live I did even going back to 92 but I
don't keep up with that stuff I only
count the big checks there no I know oh
I know
I only count the big do you know I got
it I got it
hey good to talk to you as always and
you're good dude you're a hard-working
guy and I wish you guys nothing but
success do you got a piece of
memorabilia you'd like to donate well
only memorabilia I got is stuff that's
important to me
I have none of my own memorabilia I gave
that away many many years ago and the
stuff I got it's just some people I
really admire was respect so and I'm
like I got that at my house okay yeah no
you know maybe like a time from oh you
ain't wear a tie I do wear ties now oh
if I come if I come up with something I
hook you up brother hey I appreciate
that
all right play nice on the set always
good to talk to you thank you buddy
that's Charles Barkley Hall of Famer NBA
on TNT English for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app